on passe maintenant notre chronique
junior si vous cherchez une activité
pour vos enfants ne paniquez pas notre
journaliste mélanie poké vous donne
chaque mois des idées de sport pour les
tout-petits et elle nous a rejoint sur
ce plateau bonsoir on sent michael alors
aujourd'hui nous allons parler handball
les grands champions français ont tous
commencé à pratiquer très tôt ces
disciplines nikola karabatic a fait ses
premiers pas en club à 6 ans à
strasbourg thielland meilleur à 9 ans au
club de cernier en alsace en cette
période de championnat du monde mélanie
poké vous aider à aller nous parler du
baby hand sur saint quentin en yvelines
et oui à la smb donc à
montigny-le-bretonneux il ya une section
qui a été créé il ya trois ans pour les
enfants âgés de 3 à 6 ans donc on peut
même commencer plus tôt que les
champions les entraînements ont lieu
tous les samedis entre midi et 14 heures
et un créneau encadrés par les
entraîneurs du club et les bénévoles
basé sur sur le jeu hein c'est
d'apprendre à écouter d'apprendre à
respecter les règles d'apprendre aussi à
être le faire du sport en collectivité
ça c'est la première des choses
au début c'est pas toujours facile parce
que les enfants vont recouvrir dans les
bras de papa maman mais ils écoutent ils
arrivent ils arrivent à être à
s'autodiscipliner et je précise que les
parents ne sont pas obligés de laisser
les enfants sur les deux heures est ce
que les jeunes font de la compétition
sur pas encore levé bien c'est avant
tout de l'apprentissage
il faut courir seul puis avec un ballon
faire des dribbles puis depuis des
passes et gestes techniques comme le tir
arrivent petit à petit et très vite
certains enfants devine aussi gardien
alors pour mettre tous en pratique de
cours matchs sont organisées mais le
mieux c'est d'écouter lui les
participants un papa et l'entraînement
et l'entraîneur du baby
[Musique]
on s'amuse c'est plutôt pas mal et
commence à se débrouiller un peu avec
les ballons donc tout va bien on leur
inculque les valeurs du sport
l'entr'aide la solidarité
le vivre ensemble progressent très très
très vite donc on a vraiment des
résultats en termes de motricité de jeu
collectif
ils progressent beaucoup plus vite que
les adultes l'idée est bien sûr de
s'amuser avoir de base le plus important
surtout donc les bonnes bases ça permet
après d'entrer plus facilement dans les
catégories d'âge et le club de montigny
le bretonneux est peut-être en train de
former une future pépite
merci beaucoup mais la nuit on vous
retrouvera le mois prochain pour une
nouvelle console chronique consacrée aux
juniors ont pas